la vaccination c'est la voix qui va nous
permettre de retrouver déjà les dires
une vie normale est de désengorger ceux
qui sont sous la pression quand même
depuis 15 mois je pense aux soignants
près cette priorité là le vaccin le
respect des gestes barrières et qu'il y
a de poursuivre tester tracé isolé quoi
qu'on en est dit notamment au sommet de
l'état s'il n'y avait pas les
collectivités territoriales on s'en
sortirait pas comme aujourd'hui je crois
nous sommes en train de nous en sortir
oui croyez qu'il et récréatif le le
cannabis qui a utilisé monsieur traoré
pour assassiner madame halimi pour
croyez qu'il et récréatif le cannabis
est celui qui conduit et qui provoque un
très grave accident sur la route qui
conduit sous l'emprise non je suis
défavorable à la dépénalisation
c'est clair du cannabis par contre je
pense que nous ne faisons pas assez
prévention vis-à-vis de l' usage du
cannabis
l'usagé du cannabis nécessite une
politique d'éducation de prévention et
bien sûr la lutte contre tous les
réseaux
c'est parce que nous n'aurions pas
réussi dans la lutte les avis des
réseaux de trafic que nous légalise
aurions malka dabitch et des jeux j'ai
une position là-dessus clair qu'est ce
que vous dites 5 millions d'usagers
réguliers de cannabis qui sont tous des
drogués
non je leur dis que l'usagé du cannabis
est dangereux pour eux mêmes pour leur
santé et pour autrui
mais ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
le dit que des responsables politiques
le disent
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un discours
d'hypocrisie parce que justement est ce
que vous croyez que c'est de
l'hypocrisie pardonnez moi de penser que
ce serait récréatif de consommer
régulièrement du cannabis et dans une
bouffée délirante de se conduire à
l'assassinât nous sommes là face un vrai
sujet si vous faites allusion à la faire
mais je ne peux pas me
ces passerelles j'adore de cassation
dans la route elle n'est pas drôle euros